why did you come aboard my boat for a
nice Pleasant cruise hey everybody
welcome back and it is a patreon
sponsored review because yes if you wish
you can hop on over the patreon and
there is a tier where you can actually
get me to review specific things
including books and that has happened
I got commissioned to review a book by
george RR martin and it's none of the
books in the Song of Ice and Fire series
instead it's a book as old as I am set
in the pre Civil War South caught about
vampires on a steamboat has called fever
dream now I've never read George RR
bharden before reading this book so my
entire experience with him was basically
through Game of Thrones the show and I
sort of taking into account that at
least as people who have been reading
books have been telling me is that the
first few seasons basically through
season four felt very much like his
writing whereas after that it drifted
off a little bit so my ability to say
it's true to to Martin's writing is a
little bit hampered by the fact that I
haven't read a ton of it but I'll tell
you what reading this book all the
things that people have told me about
Martin's writing you know from people
who've read Game of Thrones books I'm
like yeah yeah that that all rings
really true I
I was quite impressed with this thing so
where do we begin
okay so at the end of the day this
actually is a pretty confined narrative
it spans a number of years
strictly speaking but it's not being
told continuously there's a couple of
time jumps involved and it's ultimately
just a story about primarily one
steamboat called the fever dream and
it's captain a man named Abner Marsh who
basically is kind of like if Davos
Seaworth
from Game of Thrones ran a steamboat
it's it's funny because this book
predates any of the Game of Thrones
books and there's a number of characters
that I can't help but feel like this is
almost like a prototype version of that
character over in Game of Thrones
weren't they and I feel like Abner Marsh
is a has some of the seeds of Davos
Seaworth enemies he's rough he's he's
rough and double he's crass but he's
honorable he has a he has a strong sense
of duty and morality even though he's
not blind to the realities of the time
and place where he lives and his in his
position in that world so you've got all
that going on and there is one other POV
character I'm a rather nasty character
by the name of sour Billy Tipton and
they're the only two POV characters we
get and it does the book does something
that I tend to like which is the
protagonists are not really the most
important people in the story and what I
mean by that is if you were to sit down
and sketch out this the struggle being
had the story being told you know what's
going on
the conflicts happening and why it's
important
Abner Marsh would be a footnote and it's
our ability Tipton probably wouldn't
even get a look in because they are
adjacent to and connected to much bigger
more important people but they are the
ones who get to tell the story not
direct first person but they're the ones
whose view we are getting everything
through and that is an approach I like I
mean it's one of the reasons that I like
the movie the thirteenth war here so I
appreciate that Martin Martin's great at
evoking character through both
description and through dialogue all of
the characters in this have incredibly
distinct voices you have Abner Marsh who
is you know his entire adult life he's
been a riverboat man that's who he is
that's what he does you've got a number
of you know the people who work under
him with names like Harry Mike and you
know his pilots that help him with the
ship
you have his business partner thee the
somewhat mysterious Joshua York who's
got a very you know refined voice you've
got the the the smooth but deadly sense
that you get off there's a character by
the name of Damon Julian and he's like
okay I I'm really uncomfortable when
you're in the room and that just comes
across in the way that they're described
and the way that they speak as our
abilities just deplorable
that's just what he is and then there's
more characters than that besides but
everybody is the this is a story of very
strong personalities and I really
appreciated that and the other thing
that's worth noting about how old this
is being from nineteen
- there are a number of things in it
that I'm like was he the first one to
think of that particularly in regards to
vampire lore so like I I had first heard
the idea of Kane from the biblical story
of Cain and Abel effectively being the
first vampire or the origin of vampires
from the from vampire the masquerade
from the white wolf role-playing game
source books which was about 91 ish that
that happened this book 1982 suggested
that first so my oh okay so this
predates that thing that without white
wolf made-up and I always thought was a
neat idea okay cool and while this was
written after say interview the vampire
which you know was kind of the first
major successful work that started to
really tinker with vampire lore and
really start to look at vampires as
characters more than just as monsters it
does sort of take things to the next
level in a lot of ways from sort of what
Anne Rice had done in that area because
we get different sides of the coin with
someone like Joshua York who is you know
wants as much as possible to live and
dwell in the human world and and to be
part of it whereas you also have Damon
Julian who just he couldn't care less he
does not even think of human beings as
people they are cattle to him that is
all they ever will be and he'll move
about in their world but he doesn't care
at all and it's it's the humans to him
are just resources to be tapped and
anything they build or create is just
something for him to take or leave and
seeing that the depth of character given
to given to them is is something that if
this was written for the first time
now I think yeah okay but just knowing
how long ago he wrote this and like dang
I I don't know how well the book did
when it came out I can't imagine it was
a massive splash because I'd never heard
of it before this but I'm surprised it
doesn't come up more often in terms of
like major influences on the direction
that vampires in fiction have taken and
the only reason that I can think off
atop my head is that it didn't sell well
enough to be a major influence but
there's a lot of concepts that are
pretty standard now in terms of the
nature of vampires and the approach to
their characterization that was pretty
new for 1982 and that rhyme that I'm
really embarrassed by that but I was I
was quite impressed with this if I if I
was gonna make one particular criticism
and it is a very particular one as I
said this is set primarily about 80 85
percent of it timeline-wise
is in the pre Civil War South so there
is a language used that I will not
repeat on camera I think you know I'm
saying where I was okay reading it in
dialogue however it was a word that also
just showed up as a descriptor like in
narrative not that a character said it
but like the narration says it and that
like made me real uncomfortable like I
suppose the justification is the
narrative is always still through the
perspective of either Abner Marsh or
sour Billy Tipton and they especially
sour Billy actually would think in those
terms so I'm not gonna say there's no
narrative justification for
I will say that that that threw me off
as someone who was prepared to give a
pass to the use of the word in dialogue
given the time of the setting so that
threw me off a little bit I know that
Martin can get criticized for abuse of
female characters basically there wasn't
a ton of that there is some but again a
lot of it has to do with sort of is
within the context of kind of what you
expect out of a vampire story vampires
like young nubile prey so yeah that said
for how much given the premise how much
more of that there could have been not
nearly as much as I kind of was afraid
was gonna be in there so that that was
actually a mild relief but it is there
so if that kind of depictions sexual
violence if that's if that's an issue
for you again not it's not pervasive
across the book but it is in there so
you'd want to be aware of that the thing
is I haven't really talked about the
plot because the plot ultimately is
surprisingly straightforward in terms of
marsh hooks up with a rich guy that's
Joshua York who offers to finance him
building a brand new massive fast
steamboat and we eventually learn over
time more about Joshua and who he is and
what he's doing and then eventually they
come into conflict with Damon Julian and
it's not a massive twisty turny story
except it also kind of is because it
kept building to moments that I thought
I knew what was going to happen
then it pivoted ever so slightly for
things to go in a slightly different
direction for that not like a massive we
yank the rug out from under you but just
a little like oh no no not that way here
here that way yeah so it's just little
nudges in terms of the directions of the
story and and where it goes and the
other thing is for being a fairly
straightforward an ultimately relatively
small story just about a handful of
characters and ultimately about Abner
Marsh more than anybody else it feels
much bigger because of something you can
kind of get away with and a novel that
doesn't work as well and TV and I feel
really doesn't work on film which is
that even though the narrative is this
pretty restricted period of time you can
have a chapter or two that is just
Joshua York telling his own personal
history to Marsh and to us the audience
and suddenly we get this whole back end
of the story filled in and you know we
learn more about Damon Julianne and we
get this whole other area filled in and
it makes the whole thing feel bigger in
scope but by keeping it restricted to
Marsh it manages to feel way more
personal than the story on paper would
be or at least then I would expect it to
be I was quite impressed with this and I
definitely get why Martin's writing
inspires the kind of loyalty that has
people waiting for years on end for his
next book yeah the the craft of the
writing is just really good it gives you
just enough detail to be really
evocative of very specific times and
feelings and atmospheres while never
getting bogged down it keeps a really
good pace
the fever dream yeah I didn't know about
this but if you like George RR Martin's
writing and/or if you like vampire
stories and you haven't read this thing
yet check it out I've been doing pretty
well with the books I've gotten
commissioned for which is good because
they take more time but yeah thank you
for commissioning that one a dug it
fever dream have you read it what you
think about it if not what is your
favorite vampire story
so I let's leave movies and TV aside so
what's your favorite vampire novel or
story for me it's blood sucking fiends
the love story by Christopher Moore I
think that still takes Dobby I'm gonna
rewrite it in a while but this this was
damn good what is it for you or if you
have read this book what do you think of
it whatever your thoughts are drop
something them down in the comments
let's talk about it then there's all the
usual stuff to do like subscribe comment
patreon support hey be appreciated
there's links to all the stuff that you
would need to do so down in the
description but you also don't have to
because at the end of the day you're the
council I just run the meetings and
until next time this council is
adjourned talking with these things of
annoying
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]